the national debt has reached an
unwanted landmark passing two
trillion pounds for the first time here
we can see it climbing over the last
couple of decades rising following the
financial crisis
and passing two trillion in july as
government borrowing for the financial
year to date
rose to 150 billion pounds that's three
times last year's total
in just four months debt has soared as a
percentage of gdp
too passing a hundred percent last month
for the first time
the uk owes more than it earns in a year
we're borrowing more to cover the cost
of covid19 including 35 billion pounds
on the furlough scheme
another eight and a half on support for
the self-employed and 180 million
pounds on eat out to help out and the
government is taking
in less money to all the main tax
receipts are
down as the economy has slowed including
vat by more than 26
though much of that has been deferred
it's not all bad news
retail sales figures shown here
rebounded last month to pre-lockdown
levels a classic
v-shaped recovery driven by online sales
and a small sign
of returning economic life but the big
question is how are we
and specifically he going to pay for it
barring a miraculous recovery that boils
down to a perennial choice
cut spending or raise taxes now this is
what the chancellor
thought the uk would spend this year and
on what
welfare health and education make up the
biggest chunks of a 928 billion pound
bill but with borrowing at 150 billion
and counting that's already a six of the
budget
not far off the entire cost of the nhs
and after decade of austerity
there are no easy cuts which leaves
taxes now few choose to raise them
but in international terms the uk has a
smaller tax burden than most of our
european neighbours
33 and a half per cent more than the
united states but well below germany
and scandinavian countries so there's
some headroom and they may need it it's
not just covid the government has to pay
for its promise to level up the country
fund a social care system and we haven't
even mentioned brexit
a good job perhaps that sunak at least
has some credit in the bank